So his grandma would kill his pet dogs,
then adopt more of them and kill them.
Uh, and then she would blame the dogs
and say, "Oh, they were pissing
everywhere, so I had to kill them. They
were they were defective." And then one
day, Destiny wakes up and hears pissing
and he walks to his grandma's room and
she's standing upright just pissing on
the floor. Uh, and then she looks at
him, grunts, and then goes into bed and
falls asleep. way more child porn on
like platforms like Facebook than even
on Pornhub
>> or [__] This was the weirdest
Facebook. Okay. God, this is such a
[__] argument. Holy [__] Okay,
Pornhub is specifically for porn
>> crime to en enjoy Kiwi Farms. I think it
makes you a little bit of a
schizophrenic, but it it's not a
>> I don't agree with that. I don't agree
with that. I think most of these
communities have felt the uh the burn
from KF and what KF is willing to do to
[__] with people.
[Music]
All I know is
>> I believe the person in that picture uh
the one he posted is the person who did
get docks for some reason and he for
some reason decided I'm going to let my
>> Okay, Spencer, if you're going to donate
[__] donate more this increment of
like two Australian, you're throwing
pennies at me, [__] You're
throwing pennies at me. I appreciate the
two though. Thank you. Thank you for
that.
>> How and hinge is like ops and kev. It's
taken them like what three months to
find not just her name but be able to
like confirm it with then finding the
date of birth right down to like the
exact month or whatever the [__]
>> Oh my godes
how the [__] right. Oh
>> [__]
Some people are saying that I'm guessing
not logical.
>> Okay, this is [__] boring. You guys
know that uh
[Laughter]
>> Ethan Klein changes title on new age
three podcast for the third time and
struggles to pass 200,000 views.
[__] Wrong one. Where is it? Where is
it? [__] [__] [__] [__] Oh, yeah.
Here it is. The H3 podcast has lost
280,000 subscribers and 75% of its
monthly viewership over the past 2
years.
Look at this. Look at this.
So, what is what is his response to
this? He goes on Instagram live
and he starts streaming on Instagram
live and he starts saying, "Look at my
house. There's no way. There's no like
what? CPS got called for no reason. CPS
got called for no reason. What is right
here
next to the kids toys?
What is right here next to the kids
toys?
What is right next to the kids toys with
the dogs in view?
[Laughter]
[__] Hold on, Max. Send me that clip.
There's a clip of Ethan like walking
around his house, saying how clean his
house is. Can you find me that clip?
Don't call CPS again. I disavow. Don't
call CPS again. I just think it's so
funny that this guy's complaining. Look
how clean my house is. Look how clean my
house is. And there's a piece of dog
[__] next to the children's toys.
Do not send any more skulls. Three
skulls was enough. How much was it?
Three. Three skulls. Three skulls was
the perfect amount.
With dog rape. What is this even? You
just said this out of nowhere. You just
said this out of there. There there.
What is the What? You just said with dog
rape out of No. What? What am I supposed
to get out of this chat message? You've
just typed You haven't sent another one.
You haven't sent another one. You just
typed with dog rape.
The dogs mounting.
I think this is playing. I don't think
they're raping each other.
I don't think this is dog rape. The dogs
are playing. This is not having sex.
This is not what sex looks like.
Butterflies, don't you have a child? I
think you out of everyone would know
what that sort of situation would would
look like. Thank you for the two,
Godspeed.
I feel like you or you have a kid, don't
you? I'm pretty sure you have a kid. I
feel like you would you would know. I
feel like you would know out of
everyone.
Sequence of four pondering emojis. Thank
you. I appreciate that.
Okay. Well, this is not true. This is
not true. I mean, okay. The issue is you
need to [__] train your dogs. You
need to [__] train your dogs, okay?
Obviously, dogs are animals. They're
they don't comprehend that you're not
supposed to [__] in the house to to the
extent that we do, right? So, you're
going to have slip ups, you know, you're
going to have slip ups.
Um, but at this point, uh, Ethan has an
an obscene amount of money. He likely
has a back a backyard and maybe could
install a doggy door potentially. Um,
you know, so
listen, I I grew up with dogs my whole
life. [__] log sitting next to the
couch, okay? Uh, so, you know, sometimes
the dogs do slip up. They're animals at
the end of the day, okay? They are
animals at the the end of the day.
Um,
but yeah, probably don't go live to
4,000 viewers with a piece of dog [__]
sitting next to your kids toys.
But what if Hamas goes through the doggy
door? Well, I didn't I didn't I didn't
consider that angle of things. Okay. Is
this getting interesting yet? to check
if there's photos that have been edited,
made metadata, [__] anything like that.
>> I haven't checked into that.
>> No.
>> Oh, okay. So, so, so there has been So,
the the verification is just that the
screenshot exists. It's not that there
hasn't You guys don't know of any like
separate tools that have been used to
verify that that photo hasn't been
edited.
>> Dude, holy [__] Holy [__] dude. I feel
for women. I feel for women, dude.
[__] hair ties suck. Holy [__] Oh my
god. I'm going to crash out. I'm
actually going to [__] crash out.
I've had to [__] Dude, this [__] does
not [__] keep its like elasticity,
dude. This [__] does not keep its
elasticity. I'm going to [__] shave
my head. I'm going to [__] shave my
head. I'm like I'm I'm about to [__]
crash out. Holy [__] dude. I'm gonna
[__] go crazy. Oh my god. Okay, I'm
tying my hair back again for the [__]
third time this stream because it keeps
[__] falling out and I have a fan
pointed at me so it keeps putting the
[__] hair in my face. Holy [__] God
damn it, bro. I'm going to [__] I'm
going to I'm going to go crazy. I'm
going to go crazy. You wear hair ties?
Yes, I wear hair ties so when there's a
[__] fan in my room blowing at me, it
doesn't [__] get hair in my face
because I hate the feeling of having
hair in my face. I'm going to go [__]
bald. I'm going to shave my [__]
head. Holy [__] God. Or wear a hat. I
need to get a hat. I'll tell you why I
can't wear a [__] hat. I'll tell you
why I can't wear a [__] hat. Because
it's 100°. I have copper doorork knobs.
I live in an old ass house. I have
[__] copper doorork knobs. Okay,
listen to me, [__] I have
copper door knobs in my [__] bedroom.
And I wake up. I wake up and I I go to
turn my [__] door knob to open my
door to my bedroom to go into the [__]
downstairs into the [__] kitchen to
get a glass of water cuz I'm [__] hot
as [__] Okay. And the tap water we have
is very cold. I don't know why that is.
I don't know if that's normal. Whatever.
I go to touch the doororknob. My doorork
knob is obscenely hot. Like I'm I'm
touching that [__] and I'm worried. I'm
like, "Dude, is there a [__] fire on
the other side of this door that I don't
know about? Have I woken up in the
middle of a [__] house fire?" And I
turn the I grab the [__] doorork
knob. It's It's hot. It's [__] really
hot. And I'm I'm losing my mind. I can't
even wear a hat because then my [__]
forehead is going to get soaked in
sweat. I'm going to take the hat off.
It's going to [__] pour down my face.
Holy [__]
Don't you have AC? I can't plug No.
Okay. I'm going to [__] lose it. I'm
going to [__] lose it. Okay. I'm
going to [__] lose it. I can't I
cannot plug in an AC because if I plug
in an AC, it flips my [__] breaker. I
cannot use my computer when my family is
awake because if I do, it will flip the
[__] breaker. So, I am basically only
allowed to to use my computer at night
when everyone's asleep. So, when I'm
editing YouTube videos, when I'm
streaming, when I'm doing all this [__]
it's either when everyone's out of the
[__] house and nobody's using the
electricity or when everybody's asleep.
Okay, [__]
What do you want, Spencer? Holy [__]
dude. This is approximately 3 USD for
the premium brand hair ties. They're
worth the extra money when your hair is
long enough to ex get to get in your
bum. Time for a cut. Okay. Well, my hair
goes well past my waist. I'm at the
point where I'm just about to [__]
shave my head. Okay. I'm at the point
where I'm about to [__] shave my head
and just go bald. I'm going to I'm going
to willingly go bald. Okay. I'm [__]
losing my mind. I'm losing my [__]
mind. I'm going [__] crazy. I'm
losing my [__] mind. You can't find
archives of the [__] house tour. God
damn it. [__] Today is just ruined.
Today is just ruined. I wanted to watch
Ethan's house tour. I wanted to watch
Ethan's house tour.
Whatever, man. Whatever.
It is what it is. Lose it. I'm going to
[__] lose it. I'm going to [__]
I'm going to lose my mind. Whatever,
dude. Whatever. What are they saying on
the stream?
>> If you just edited evidence like
explicitly to try to make people think
this, then I I don't know what you won.
you you explicitly manipulated like
evidence to try to discredit people like
that then if you're successful in lying
to people to try to discredit them right
you actually create convincing evidence
of your wrongdoings I think
>> I think I think the idea you guys would
be able to be convinced by a photoshop
>> um multiple photoshops from like
oh I'm guessing a lot of these accounts
>> why is Auggie RFC in the chat saying TDD
D. What? Don't say that, man. Don't say
that.
>> Actually, I think Am I Am I crazy or
would you have had to have control of
those accounts?
>> No, this is just this is a just a really
big part in my thought process because
let's assume that Rose Let's just assume
everything is as
>> Are you watching the stream? Just call
in cuz I don't even know what they're
[__] talking about. What am I
supposed to call in to say? You want me
to just call in and and just sit there
and listen and rip the content? I I'd
rather just rip the content from outside
the fence until I know if I want to call
in or not. I want to talk to Really. I
want to I want to [__] argue with
Really, dude. I want to scream at this
[__] Really guy. I want to scream and
yell and shout at this [__] Really
guy.
All right. I just asked someone else if
they wanted to call in as well. I'll see
if I can get them. That'd be f It'll be
funny if I get them to call. Very very
very difficult to overstate
>> like how much evidence there is.
>> I I agree with you.
>> I haven't seen the totality of it. I
haven't I haven't seen the totality of
the evidence um and stuff like that.
I've just seen like some of the the face
comparison analysis
uh stuff like that. Um I've seen the the
some of the other [__] I just haven't
gone into it that deep. Uh I'll believe
that you feel confident.
Jared kick sucks. Holy [__]
A
kick [__] blows. Holy [__]
>> into being able to blow his brain.
>> Jesus Christ.
>> Can't bring himself to do it.
>> That is dark, dung devil. And I kind of
disavowed that. Okay, disavowed that a
little bit. That was a little That was a
little crazy. Okay, that was a little
crazy. Uh, thank you for the no, though.
Thank you for the five. Somebody said
that he's uh he's just trying to ruin
his life so it could push him over the
edge to end it. And I was like, you know
what? That's a little too far for me.
Uh, sorry. Anyway,
>> Dickers is just sitting, but Dickers
isn't live. I feel like he can justify.
Okay, you know, I'm going to call
Dickers. Can I [__] call this Dickers
guy? Where's this [__] Dickers guy?
Can I just call this Dickers guy? I
almost called the wrong guy. That would
have been bad. I'm calling this [__]
Dickers guy.
I need someone to explain to me why Rose
being 17 is bad. That's what I need.
That's what I need.
Answer
the answer the phone dickers.
[Applause]
He's not picking up, dude. He's not
picking up. Who else do I have on my
friends list?
Junk drawer.
How old is Destiny when he's texting
her? Like mid30s. It was like 3 years
ago about like couple years ago. Some
mid30s
call Junk Drawer Gaming. I'll DM him and
I'll ask Junk Drawer.
Can I call you? I'm on stream cuz my
Here's my thing, right? I'm looking at
this I'm looking at this from the angle
of I'm I'm arguing with a DGER, right?
That's how I'm looking at this from.
Okay, that's how I'm looking at this
from. I'm I'm looking at this from the
perspective of if I'm going to make an
argument, I have to make an argument to
someone who is pro Destiny and obviously
isn't going to care about the age being
17, right? So, when I'm thinking about
this, I'm thinking, okay, here's my
argument for why this is bad because I
feel like this is a pretty a pretty
strong argument. Destiny has reckless
disregard for the age of who he is
sexing with. Destiny has reckless
disregard. And due to this reckless
disregard, he has messaged at least one
minor who he did not care to properly
verify the age and sent them pornography
and then plan to meet up with them and
have sex with them, right? Uh that is
that is my issue. The issue isn't with
the [__] age. All right? Because does
does this happening uh like and then 5
months later suddenly it's okay, right?
When the girl turns 18, suddenly it's
all right. Uh like no that's that's
obviously not how this works. If this
happened in the girl could have been 18.
The fact that he didn't verify the age
is the issue. He has reckless disregard
for the people he is interacting with
sexually online. Right?
That is the issue. That is the issue.
That is the moral issue I have.
Obviously, there's the legal aspect,
which you know, if he exchanged
pornography with this woman, received
CESAM, uh, and, you know, potentially,
you know, planned to cross state lines,
uh, and and meet up with her and have
sex with her and stuff like that.
Obviously, he should be, uh, you know,
the law should handle that, whatever.
But I'm looking at this from the
perspective of, uh, arguing with a DGER,
so I I can't say like, well, she was
under the 80%.
Destiny crawled some route could run.
True. Unfortunately, I didn't exchange
sex tapes with a 17-year-old. I don't
have that much uh in common with uh with
Destiny, it seems.
Who do I have on my friends list? I can
call
PooPot. Let's call Poo Pot. Can I call
you? Let's call Gilded Pooh. Let's call
Gilded Pooh.
I'll DM Stardust.
Stardust thoughts. Oh, she
Stardust blocked me. What the [__]
What the [__]
Stardust blocked me.
Oh, man.
Whatever.
Whatever, dude.
I don't have that many friends I can
call. I need to get more characters that
I can rely on.
I need to get more characters that I can
rely on to call
Smith. Smith.
Should I debate pedophilia with Smith?
Do not call Smith. Smith is epic. Smith
is cool as [__] Okay,
I asked Fairy Queen to call, but I don't
think she will. But yeah, no, I think
that's a good argument, and I I I've had
some push back on this argument, and I
feel like uh I feel like it's good
because Destiny and DGG and all these
people are going to do the whole like,
but 17 in 365 days or whatever. And it's
like, bro,
like you you got to get around that. Why
do you use an avatar? Show your face
because I'm like I don't I'm not a
looker. All right. I'm not a looker.
I feel like this. Okay. Dude, you guys
are like [__] Why don't you show
your face? Why don't you show Why do you
think I'm not showing my [__] face,
[__] Why do you think I'm not
showing my [__] face, [__] Huh?
Why do you think I'm hiding behind a
[__] cat avatar, [__] idiot? Use
some common sense, [__] Don't know.
Gold. No. No. Unless it is an obscene
amount of money. If I get paid like
[__] thousands of dollars, I'll face
reveal, but I'm not sacrificing my
privacy. Especially when I am covering
people who are known to docs.
Doesn't sound Doesn't sound uh doesn't
sound like the smartest move to make
right now.
Tuna. Yeah, we'll call Tuna.
I'm not opposed to face revealing
eventually.
[Laughter]
Bro,
hold on. Big news. Big news. Hold on.
[Laughter]
We'll get him on call, folks. We'll get
him on call.
Uh, no. I to to on a real note, I value
my privacy to some extent.
Okay. Well, he's he's [__] not saying
yes immediately. I'm just going to call
Tuna. I on a real note, okay, on a real
note, I value my privacy to some extent.
Um
uh and I am not opposed to sacrificing
my privacy. However, okay, here's the
here's the contention I have. I don't
make a lot of money doing this. I don't
get a lot of clout doing this. I don't
get a lot of benefit from doing this.
So, I feel like sacrificing my privacy
for very little gain uh is not really
something I'm willing to do. Uh if I was
getting more views and if I was getting
more more money and if I was getting um
more clout and [__] [__] yeah. I'd face
reveal. I don't care. Uh but the the
sacrificing of my privacy, which I do
value for like not a lot of gain, uh not
something I'm willing to do right now.
If I was making like more money, I
wouldn't be opposed. Oh, let's call
Gilded first.
Gilded Pooh,
>> what's up?
>> Why is Why is exchanging sex tapes with
a 17-year-old bad? Gilded Pooh.
>> Um, I would say it's a crime, and that'd
be about the extent of my opinion on it.
>> That's all. It's just a crime.
>> Yeah. Outside of that, I don't really
care all that much. So, you think it's
you think it's like base to [__] a
17-year-old?
>> No, I think it would be weird.
>> Define weird.
So, you're asking two different
questions. You're asking about porn and
then you're asking about having sex with
a 17-year-old. In the majority of the
country,
uh, the United States, almost every
state but 11, 17 would be above the age
of consent. So if you're talking about
[__]
>> it crosses and so it would be a felony
stall.
>> Oh
well that's [__] I wouldn't do it
anyway. Like so for me personally like
>> how much money would someone have to
give you to [__] a 17-year-old in a in a
state where it's legal to do so?
>> $15 million.
>> 15 mill? No, you wouldn't go 14. You
wouldn't go 14.
No, we'll go uh 17 a year per or a
million per year.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> All right. What do you think about this
Destiny stuff? Destiny was about to fly
out a 17-year-old to have sex with them
>> and then he her
thoughts on that, Gilded Bear. What do
you think about that?
Uh,
that's that's pretty [__] [__]
And makes me wonder,
does he stop at 17? Does it go down to
16? Like,
>> it goes down to 15. He wanted to [__] a
15-year-old when he was 24. He said she
had big tits and she was hot. That was
epic.
>> That's news to me, but yikes.
>> It goes down to at least 15.
Uh, I mean, like, look,
it's not that hard to convince me
Destiny is a pedophile. I don't even
like Destiny. So,
>> what about me? Am I your favorite
pedophile?
>> Wait, you're a pedophile? Thought you
were like a a
>> I got to go. I got to go. Okay.
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
Hey,
>> what's up, pussycat?
>> Is Destiny based still? Can we Can we
trust him to make the video essay on
January 6th?
>> Uh, is he based? No. I think that he has
a fire under his ass. So maybe he'll uh
he'll throw in a Hail Mary, try really
hard because, you know, he needs to win
people back, you know. But is he based?
Definitely not.
>> What do you think about uh
what do you think about Destiny doxing
this 17-year-old, which which led to
them finding out who she was?
I didn't know that he doxed her. He
doxed her.
>> Yeah. Is it her?
>> Yeah. So that's that's literally how
they found out who she was. I can send
you a link to this if you want. Um
so he says in his DG offline chat, "It's
funny because they think I'm hiding
stuff about Rose since she's underageed.
The only reason I haven't actually
mentioned much about her is because I
know it makes them dig harder if they
want more to go on." and he links a uh a
Discord like image. That's a Discord
like attachment link. And then he uh he
says she went to blank college. Good
luck. So he provides an uncensored image
of her face and what school she goes to.
>> Is every [__] you know the meme with
the the black guy and the Trump hat with
the assault rifle? Message heard,
Destiny. Message heard. It's like that
community has got to be so [__] full
of just I mean they're not they're not
capable of doing any any violence until
one of them suddenly is. He kind of
burnt the Islam bridge though so maybe
he's got some safe maybe he's he doesn't
have that many domestic terrorists in
his community just autists. But I think
>> it's pedophiles, but they're like chill
and they wouldn't actually do anything,
but they like uh they like will, you
know, kind of walk on the line. And then
also it's like socialists, I think, is
is kind of what his audience is. But I
guess I'm I'm the main thing I'm um
I'm just baffled by is the fact that he
doxed this girl and then is somehow
upset when people find out she's a
minor. I think that's the
I I can't imagine uh
what is going through this guy's head.
Why Why would you do That's like Epstein
That's like Epstein
raping a kid and then saying, "Hey, by
the way, this is their address. Just so
you know, go find out about who this
person is." This is not a winning
strategy, I fear. And I'm I'm I guess
I'm kind of confused. This is like um
this is like who was it that deflated
their their footballs? The Patriots or
whatever. This is like when they
deflated their football to like try to
win.
>> I don't think that he's thinking very
hard. I do think that he's just straight
up like an emotional vengeful, you know,
spiteful little cretton, right? So,
>> this is not like the the the idea of
like 7D chess Stephen is the is kind of
the stupidest thing ever.
>> I mean, his brain his dick has more
brain cells than he does like half of
the time. It seems like he's mostly
like, you know, sex first, uh, vengeful
spite after,
then produce a narrative that makes it
look like you were actually
masterminding the process. But uh truly
it's little Benell
micro Benel that's steering the ship uh
in that in that particular body I'd say
>> I don't know if I've just I've just you
know not had uh good experiences but
I've I've had sex a handful of times
believe it or not and it is not that
good to be doing [__] like this. Maybe
I'm missing something. Maybe I'm maybe I
maybe there's something I haven't, you
know, done yet that just kind of clicks.
But sex is kind of uh sex is kind of
mid. It's kind of like not worth the
effort, you know?
>> I'd rather like eat a pizza hot pocket
and watch uh watch like Criminal Minds.
It's kind of way more up my alley. I
don't know.
>> Sex gets a lot better after you get like
domestically battered by a woman cuz
then you have something to prove. So
then every time that you [__] it's you
proving to yourself that you are a
desirable man to other women. Usually
it's it's mommy issues. I think that
with Destiny, it seems like it might
have started actually with with that
>> with the
>> Say again what?
>> Oh, you you didn't know that.
>> What happened?
>> So his grandma would kill his pet dogs,
then adopt more of them and kill them.
Uh and then she would blame the dogs and
say, "Oh, they were pissing everywhere,
so I had to kill them. They were they
were defective." And then one day,
Destiny wakes up and hears pissing and
he walks to his grandma's room and she's
standing upright just pissing on the
floor. Uh, and then she looks at him,
grunts, and then goes into bed and falls
asleep.
>> The prototype for the infinite rape
machine was the infinite dog killing
machine.
>> Yeah. Wait, people in chat don't even
know about You guys don't know about
this. Hold on, I'll find a clip. But
yeah, no, that's real. That's real.
That's Israel.
>> The dog piss. The dog piss auto kennel.
>> What the [__] That's
>> Yeah, he was a part of the He was a part
of the the dog pissing uh the dog
pissing killing machine,
>> you know.
>> Turbo kennel. Hell yeah. Turbo kennel.
Yeah, that's kind of crazy.
>> I didn't know that [__] you know,
didn't know that his grandma was
literally Adolf Puper. That's crazy. She
was just churning through him.
>> That's crazy.
I my
was she an alcoholic? My dad was an
alcoholic and he once pissed in my
bedroom because
you know it was where the bathroom used
to be in the previous house. So he came
home so [__] up once that he did that
and he never lived that [__] down.
>> Here, take a take a take a gander at my
screen really quick.
>> Woman and kill dogs about it. That's
crazy.
>> Go ahead and grab a tell me when you're
watching. and I I'll play this little
clip.
>> Okay, one sec. One sec.
>> Okay, hit play.
>> Like these, Destiny has explained he
learned to be independent early on in
life. He also learned how to detach. His
story of particular note is his grandma,
as Destiny tells it, would routinely
adopt a dog. The dog would misbehave due
to lack of training, and his grandma
would put it down. When I was pretty
young, maybe like fifth grade, I think
she did this to two dogs that me and my
little sister were like very attached
to. I remember obviously being
incredibly upset when that happened
because they were like my the two dogs
that I like the most. But then after
that, I kind of stopped caring so much
about each individual dogs. I knew that
it was it had like a 12-month timer on
it basically.
One of the days that I got up to leave,
it was like 4:30, 4:45. I heard the dog
pissing in my grandma's room. I'd never
seen it before. And this dog was taking
some massive piss. And I remember that I
opened my door and my grandma had her
hands on the bed and she was just kind
of like barely like leaning over and she
was just pissing all over the floor. And
she kind of looked at me um and I kind
of looked at her and I didn't say
anything and she kind of like grumbled a
little bit and then she like crawled
back into bed and um and yeah. And I
left and I was like, "Holy fuck."
Despite events like these or his parents
mismanaging their wealth to terrible
results, Destiny contends he had a
pretty good life. While his
>> Jeez,
>> despite the dog despite the dog murder
and my grandma pissing in front of me, I
had a pretty good life. I had a I had a
I had a pretty good
>> Wait, hold on. Do you think this is why
he became a carpet cleaner?
>> Oh [__] You might be on to something
there,
>> bro. Stanley Steamer. It starts at the
core. It starts with the family
trauma based career path.
>> He uh Oh, it's like uh it's like you
know germaphobes. They like obsessively
clean their hands. You think he had uh
he had like those what are they called?
Rug doctors. He had a rug doctor. He'd
obsessively like shampoo his carpet over
and over again. He'd put like plastic
over his carpet to try to preserve it.
God,
>> there's no way. There's no way that that
cuz he's like talking that's that's the
kind of thing where
>> even when you think it doesn't have
lasting damage that's like structurally
rewired your brain dude
>> well I mean cuz you think think about it
from the perspective of like a little
seven-year-old kid right like you get
these dogs and you're like oh I love
playing with these dog like I love I
love puppies right I love these guys and
then every year your grandma puts them
down and it's because your grandma's oh
they were misbehaving. They were pissing
everywhere. And then one day you you
open your door, you hear the pissing.
You're assuming you're going to find the
dog. And then you open the door and you
just see your your grandma presumably
half naked pissing on the floor.
Like that that is like there something
something in your brain. The sinapses,
the little the little uh you know you
know Fallout 4, that scene where you go
into Kellogg's head and you see the
memories. Those are like if Destiny had
a video game, we go into his mind in
Fallout 4. That's one of the memories
we're going to see that turned him into
like the baby kidnapper or whatever. The
cybernetic baby kidnapper.
>> I'm actually thinking about it now. If
Stephen King wrote his life story, he
would have killed his grandma for
pissing on the rug.
>> So that's like later as a seveny old
where it went.
>> Say it again.
>> Like later in life or as a
seven-year-old?
>> No. What? while he was a seven-year-old.
Cuz like he learned from his grandma,
what do you do when something pisses on
the carpet? You put it down.
>> Oh,
>> grab the hatchet, little Destiny. Grab
the hatchet.
>> Well, okay. Well, I I'm thinking he
would use something akin to like a bread
knife so that way people would assume it
was the dog that did it,
>> right? So, he's he's using this bread
knife cuz I'm assuming I'm assum like
Banel, that's kind of an Italian-esque
name. I'm assuming spaghetti. The
previous night they had the baguette.
The the bread knife still on the counter
unwashed. He grabs the bread knife and
he starts slashing. And then inevitably
when the when the authorities arrive,
they see these wounds, these gashes and
like obviously it was the dog. So then
they assume the dog's misbehaving. And
Destiny learns at that moment. You don't
just get push put down for for
misbehaving. You get put down for things
that are above your control. This dog
had no idea what was happening. In this
dog's mind, God has just punished him
simply for existing.
So at this moment, Stephven's both
worlds, both worlds, one world crashed
and burned and another was born. And
then in that same moment, that other
second world that he had now learned to
cope with has has then again uh imploded
upon itself. He's living in his third
world where everyone's punished no
matter what. Everyone gets punished
ultimately. even the 17-year-olds who
he's soliciting for uh sex,
>> which is I'm assuming, right, doctor.
But
>> how does this get back to having a
hunger for cunn?
>> You know, I'm
um
>> I don't know. You know, Destiny also did
a ton of incest debates. Do you think
this had a connection to the grandma?
Honestly, I I think it's I mean it it
all just call comes down to him just
being like completely cold to to base
intuition. Like if we're going to go go
real skitso analysis on this [__] it's
that he learned right can't [__]
anything.
>> He was also molested. I don't know if
you know that.
>> He was molested.
>> Yeah, on Reddit he said he was molested.
What's his definition of being molested?
>> He was touched as a kid. So, I I I think
the lore is Someone link me the Reddit
post. Someone in chat link me the the
Reddit post. I'll take a look at it. The
lore is I believe I'm going off of
memory here. I believe Destiny was like
victim blaming molesting victims, right?
Knife point. Yeah, he had a knife in his
back. I think like someone put a knife
in his back and was like raping him or
something like that. Um,
>> he knew this,
>> but I believe what what happened is on
his streams he was like victim blaming
molestation victims, right?
Um,
and people were like freaking out like
why are you like they they don't know
any better. Like what are you doing?
This is crazy. And he made a Reddit post
in response and was like I was actually
molested and my molestation was way more
violent, right? I got molested way
harder than all of these people. I know
how it affects you. you're you're you're
being a baby about it, I think, is what
what happened.
>> It'd be even like at the end of it and
it was like, listen, I know that my
molestation was my fault, which means
that your molestation was your fault.
I was asking for it, [__]
>> Well, I don't know if he was asking for
it. It seems like um he gets very he
gets very agitated when it's brought up
to him. What's that? [__] What's that
clip? Connor Connor uh you know who
Connor points counterpoints on a stream
with Destiny. He says uh
he says, "Hey Queenan," because Queman
DM'd Connor. He was like, "Hey,
hey, you know, Queman, hold on. Let me
get let me get I need to make this like
uh suspenseful. Let me get uh
one sec. Give me like two seconds. Here
we go.
Hold on. Okay, this is antilimactic.
It's not loading. Hold on. [__]
>> Okay. Well, now this is my my plan here
is just completely [__] up. Holy [__]
>> Yeah, just tell us just tell us about
how like Connor snitched on Queen saying
something about Destiny's rape.
>> Oh, here we go. Okay. Yeah. So, he was
in a call with Destiny and he said, "Um,
Queenman DM'd me a question to ask you."
And he said, he said, "If I don't ask
it, I'm gay and I don't want to be gay,
so I'm going to ask it to you." And then
he asked the question, "Were you
molested, Destiny?"
And then Destiny is like visibly taken
back a little bit. He's like, "What? No,
no, I they can have their gay little
fantasies about me. Doesn't make it
true." and he's like visibly agitated,
visibly upset about this. He never
denies that he was molested. He never
says no.
I think he was raped as a little kid
with a knife in his back.
I don't know if you still have your
dramatic music playing. You did I You're
not playing it over here, so I'm just
I'm just letting you have your
>> SP. Yeah. Well, I mean, you can you can
chime in if you want. That That's kind
of it. He just He didn't deny it.
>> Yeah. No, I I mean, I I think I don't
care what happened to him or what didn't
happen to him. It it does it does seem
like I agree with your base point that
obviously none of these Destiny freaks
are going to care because they're like
ends justify means people and that's the
real thing that you're butdding up
against. So, even if you like, you know,
create an iron defense about, you know,
this wasn't pedophilia, it was reckless
uh sexing, I don't think they're going
to listen to you no matter what cuz they
don't see it as a conversation they're
willing to appeal to. Well, I'm I'm I'm
saying like if I was able to talk to a
DGER, right, I would uh that's the
argument that I would get because I feel
like that's that's the one that's a
little harder to to deal with because I
don't think Destiny is a a pedophile.
I'll call him one for fun because I
think it's a funny insult, but like
genuinely I think he's had enough adult
partners to kind of
I guess skirt past the pedophile label.
Um, but I do think reckless disregard is
a is probably the way to go with the
with fighting a DGER. Yes,
>> I I do think that he has the sort of
like
sexual decadence of your average
pervert. And maybe the more cutting
thing would say be to say that he's
acting as pornographer and he's
radicalizing a 17-year-old into wasting
their entire life being a decadent
pervert despite probably not having the
money to satisfy that desire the way
that he can. I I think that that's, you
know, getting into a certain point
because that is theore.
>> I would think that's good if he knew,
but I I don't know if he knew her age
while he was talking to her, right?
>> No, it's not about that. I'm saying that
like when you're going down the ticket
of the recklessness.
I'm saying that
>> every like when he's just going around
starting sex lives with a bunch of
random people, he's not taking account
of the fact that he is like a decadent
pervert with a bunch of money and a
bunch of prestige. He can just like
survive. Like what happens if Destiny
gets AIDS? He's got prep instantly.
Turbo prep. He's got types of prep
you've never even heard of. He could get
triple AIDS. He could [__] a monkey.
Nothing would happen to him. So if he
goes around spreading that kind of like
sexual appetite and perversion onto
other people,
I think that that's the more dangerous
part, which is kind of what the problem
with pedophiles is to begin with is
which is, you know, one obviously you're
a [__] rapist, but the other one is
like you're typically traumatizing a
child into becoming an adult pedophile.
It's like this seems to reproduce form
of sort. So, it's just like you like I
think that they will at least
acknowledge the fact that like this
17-year-old is like being put into a
really weird position where they're
being paid to become a sort of like
crazy pervert.
>> Yeah.
>> But whatever.
>> Yeah. I mean, I don't disagree with
that. Um,
do you think everyone is in a FIA file?
Uh what age range is a fubile?
>> It's like uh it's like post pebbassant,
right?
>> I I mean you got to give me like r like
like a rough number like teenager
teenager like so like for 13 to 19 or
whatever.
>> No, I don't buy that. I think that I
think that
number one I so especially when people
talk about the idea that like the
natural preference is that age range and
everybody just morally abstracts away
from it. I don't buy that [__] I think
that that's like I think that there's an
amount of
evidence that people who are cognitively
delayed, people who have like, you know,
really bad autism, like the people who
keep getting caught in the pedophile
catcher videos where a 13-year-old with
a hammer meets a a [__] inside of a
target and chases them around while
they, you know, scream. I think that
that type of person is, you know, you
the argument seems to be people are
like, "Oh, well, why is it that dumb
people who don't understand morals and
social conventions. Wouldn't that be the
And it's like I think that they're just
cognitively delayed. I think cognitively
delayed people probably can have a
sexual attraction that's in that area,
but it's like it's representative of a
of a of a problem.
>> I don't think that that's normal once
you're like in your 20s and 30s. I think
that you probably I think that that like
the 16 17 18 is when some people have
developed enough that it's not a
pedophilic
uh anomaly that people are attracted to
them. But they obviously then also have
to have this like other thing which is
when they learn the age and they learn
the expected relational thing, they're
disgusted. Cuz I also think that that's
the other layer of it is like if you're
not grossed out by the idea
that the sexual engagement between you
and that other person is going to kind
of
it's going to be bad.
it's going to be like it's going to blow
up in the end. If you're attracted to
the explosiveness of it, then that's its
own [__] thing. I think that that's
some people. They like they love the
idea of like young love or whatever. Um,
that's more of female pedophiles though.
That's your female Aphibile.
>> Have you found your your soulmate yet,
>> Tuna?
>> Yeah, I got a fiance, dude.
>> Do you love her?
Yeah.
>> How much money would someone have to pay
you to shoot her in the head with a
Glock 19 Gen 4?
>> Um, not going to do that one actually.
Don't think I could live it down. Think
I would ruin my life permanently. Uh,
and also kill a person.
>> What if What if they had the What if
they had the mind erasing Ray and you
would forget that you killed her and
you'd forget all about her, but you'd be
given the money after? How much money?
And then if you say no, you they also
>> I just really I really genuinely don't
think number one
that I'm not that the person post eraser
would not be curious enough to
rediscover the reason I got the money.
But in this complete fantasy world where
there's a mind erasing ray, there's
probably also some other technologies.
Uh whatever.
>> There's machines and gizmos and gadgets
and whatnot in this in this scientific
laboratory type deal. Yeah.
>> Can you bring her back? Is that
something that you can do? Is death
basically gone?
>> You can clone her like Dolly the sheep.
Yeah. You know Dolly the sheep, right?
>> I No, but I'm just going to assume they
they cloned a sheep.
>> They cloned a sheep. And they've also
been cloning people for around uh 20
years, but they keep it on the down low
and they don't really talk about it a
lot. But there are clones that exist and
it's it's there's like I mean we can get
into that later but yeah there's clones
that exist. They've been cloning people
>> but that yeah in the 70s they cl they
cloned a sheep named Dolly.
>> Well now that you've convinced me and I
cuz I've I've taken everything that you
said for the last 10 minutes with
absolutely no critical thought that
there are clones. I have no way of
knowing that the one I'm dating right
now is the original. So I think I have
to take it for like
>> it's like Fallout 4. We've kind of we've
kind of brushed on the topic of Fallout
4. But if you kill a a clone in Fallout
4, there's a little little microchip in
their brain. You know that
>> it's like drowning the witch. If she's a
real woman,
she's a real woman. There will be no
microchip.
>> But I can be sure that she's a clone.
>> If only to know whether or not I've
fallen in Yeah, you're right. Yeah,
you're right. I got to do it. I got to
do it. So, would you clone yourself? How
much is How much
>> would you clone yourself? They have the
technology.
>> Oh, uh, yeah. I have no problem cloning
myself. Why? Why would I?
>> What would you do your What would you do
with it?
>> Uh,
I'd probably just make them slaves. I
just have like a 10 10 uh 10 person team
of slaves because I don't really want to
create like a a structure where some of
them have to whip one another. I want it
to be like manageable by me alone. I'd
have all of them do all of the things
that I don't want to do but have to do.
Um and I would just like I'd be so good
at it too because like can you imagine
anybody who's a better slave driver than
yourself? I know their ticks. I know
their fears, their insecurities.
>> Someone in my Someone in my chat thinks
you're Grock. because yesterday I talked
to Grock about rape. Um, so someone in
chat right now thinks that you're
actually Grock right now.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, I don't know if that speaks to I
guess maybe the the type of responses
you're giving, but I just think that's
funny that someone someone thinks that
this is a second Grock stream and and
you are you are the AI.
I think that's it. I don't know what
else there is to say. I t I touched on
the fiance killing.
>> Man, I got that's all I got. You came in
here. You you asked me whether
>> yeah I mean like I don't think we have
much more to to touch on. Um we touched
on Destiny's watching his grandma piss.
We touched on how much money it would
take for you to kill your clone wife and
then what you would do with a clone if
you cloned yourself like Dolly the
sheep. They did that in the 70s. Um
I think that's it.
>> Who did that? Was it China?
>> No Chinese Cambridge or some [__]
>> Cambridge is kind of like you know
structurally Chinese.
Dolly the Sheep. They do like frog egg
cloning as well. The scientific legacy
of Dolly the sheep. Dolly the sheep
clone. Yeah, there's videos of it
binging. You know that? There's videos
of the sheep bing. 1996. The sheep goes
ba. It's like some sort of real
scientific anomaly. They've cloned a
sheep. They also cloned humans, but they
don't really publicize a lot on that.
There is there is information about it,
but yeah, they've also stuffed it and
mounted it. So the Dolly the sheep is
immortalized in a
>> Are we still are we still talking about
the the are we talking about the humans
being stuffed and mounted or
>> no dolly is a sheep they haven't done
that to a person I don't think
>> they
you know okay suddenly suddenly you're
buying you know everything that the news
tells you
>> well I well I mean what is the the
alternative here is is something akin to
uh there's a person inside of a sheep
food.
>> Oh god.
>> And I don't want to think about that.
Listen, Tuna, I don't want to keep
you're You sound like you're in a car. I
feel like you've just gotten home from
work. I don't want to keep you. I don't
know.
>> I literally am in a car and just got
home from work.
>> Yeah, I'll I'll let you get to it. Thank
you for calling in, Smile.
>> No problem, Smile.
>> Bye. Love you. God, what an [__]
That's a joke. I like I like tuna. I
like tuna. This [__] this [__] ass
sheep, man.
>> Her name is Dolly. Seven months old, she
may not be the monster imagined in a
science fiction fantasy. Yet, the cuddly
Finn Dorset lamb may represent a major
in the history of genetic engineering
on an ordinary farm in Scotland. Some
>> cabal call on rellies. What does that
mean?
>> After this, right? [__] like that. And
so he decides to put this information
out there because he doesn't care about
doxing this person. Um to make anybody
associated with Kiwi Farms and Kiwi
Farms look bad. Turns out that either
Kiwi Farms got the right person and he's
[__] his pants right now or um Kiwi
Farms doesn't have the right person and
he's uh he's like just like raking in
the the basking in the glowing
>> and figuring out the wrong person.
>> So I think I think that could be that is
definitely possible that
>> I bought a ton of cup of noodles. I have
a ton of a lot of cup of noodles next to
me. I
>> just don't want to quite get into it on
stream like exactly what it was. I feel
like it would take a lot to make this
doable like to to do this bait and
switch. I think it takes too I think it
would take too much. But let's say he
felt like he'd seen something that yeah
puts her over 18. Um
then maybe just maybe if he thought like
I said maybe it's the uh maybe it's like
oh she started college a year earlier or
something.
>> I did actually. I'll tell you. So I got
I got tuna. I got I I'll tell you what I
got at the grocery store. This bloody
teeth person. Okay, I'll tell you what I
got at the grocery store. I got I got
uh I got six cup of noodles,
one for each day until I go to the
grocery store next.
I got tuna as well for tuna sandwiches
because they're high in protein, you
know, very good, very good substitute.
I got carrots and I got a bag of apples.
That is what I got at the grocery store.
And that has lasted me about three days.
It's Wednesday. It's lasted me about
three days.
All right. Lasted me about 3 days. And
I'm I'm living like Larry. Tuna
sandwiches are disgusting. Okay. Well, I
mean, I don't I don't know what to tell
you. Uh, what do you want to hear? What
do you want to hear? What do you want to
hear? Damn, you're poor. I'm not that
poor. I'm not that poor. I'm not that
poor. I'm like I'm like middle class or
something.
I'm like middle class. I need to put
like a sock around my [__] doororknob
though. My copper [__] doorork knob.
Jesus. Jesus. Bleak
or something. Right.
>> So between the filming between
>> would have had to have been very
recently that he saw this
>> information.
>> Well, yeah. He he leaked it. He leaked
it like three months ago, right? The
Willie Mack interview was 5 months ago.
So you've got a twomonth window where
after the Willie Mack interview when
he's got a handful of nothing, he sees
the information
that then makes him confident enough to
go out and confirm stuff that well, Kiwi
Farms has kind of already suspected
>> and all the other stuff where he's like
finding this girl who looks exactly like
her but isn't like her and he knows that
this girl.
>> He said, "Hold on. He said that was
>> that's the narrative that I don't
actually saying.
>> I just wanted to see what your guys's
response was to that because if he could
find somebody to do that, it would
literally be perfect. Jtock would
literally never be able to talk about
Destiny ever again. It's the godhand for
Destiny.
>> Oh, this JTO. Oh, that's the guy who
believed a photoshop on this
>> channel is they've put a bar on the
channel. I can't even join. They've
limited the channel. They've limited the
I can't even join. This is so [__] up.
This is so [__] up. Whatever, dude.
>> Kind of insane.
>> Whatever.
>> You could say it would be insane. What
I'm saying is that if that was the case,
like if he could just find somebody who
looked similar to them, who had a was in
a similar age group to them, stuff like
that. Um, and maybe Photoshop some [__]
then or have somebody else do it for
him. [__] Uh then
>> I'm sorry if he went through an
elaborate like conspiracy with people to
like get other people to Photoshop [__]
and to to like plant this evidence and
send it to like the Kiwi Farms people
and like do all this. If he went through
all of that, I'm like, "Oh, you baited
me. You you won. You like you actually
made yourself
>> That's what I'm saying. That's that
that's the best scenario for him."
>> Okay. And I just wanted to see if there
was
>> anything. Let me in. let me enter this
[__]
>> uh that could kind of push that in the
opposite direction. But yeah, no, that
isn't my what I think is the most
reasonable.
>> Yeah, he posted this just a short while
ago is in this [__] call. I got this
guy on my screen now because he's joined
the waiting room. Look at this guy.
>> I mean, there's nothing I can really say
slashdo. I still don't know if any of
the info is true or real. I have no way
to contact this person. And even if it
is true, the person likely literally
lied about their age to me age by two
years. Look at this [__] that's in
this call with me right now.
>> Proof of her age because he literally
was he was literally honeypotting her
and sex trafficking a minor. Lol.
>> Does that change?
>> Yeah. The the the more stuff that he
says like for instance, another good
point that you brought up was him
canceling anything else
>> he owns.
>> I don't know when that goes on, but you
said he canceled anything else. And
>> I'll just assume that that's the case.
Um but all of that [__] it starts erode
well it doesn't erode my theory
necessarily. It erodess the theory that
um it isn't her. Right. My theory could
still be the case that he had
significant reason to believe she was
>> like a nice young gentleman.
>> But it's like dawned on him that
actually that was totally not legit and
he got lied to.
But even if that was the case, I don't
know why he wouldn't now play his hand
and be like,
>> "Fuck,
>> oh man, you know, I saw an ID last week
or something like that. She really lied
to me.
>> What the [__] is that?"
>> Or, "I saw a birth certificate last
month.
>> Someone just DM me their arts and
crafts."
>> Uh uh. or her friends DM'd me with like
pictures of her and Xgrade
>> and you know correlated that or
something.
>> But he's got seen that in like a like a
two-month window to never have brought
it up when he was asked by like Willie
Max show um and also seen it in a way
that he wouldn't be able to like easily
like transmit or like share with
somebody else.
>> Well, no. He could have easily
transmitted it prior to there, but then
just wanted to discredit Kiwi Farms and
all these other people. He could have
done that.
>> Dude, I'm like clicking my pen. Do you
guys hear this right now? The internet
is like going against him. I don't
>> I'm [__]
>> Okay, I got to resort. I got to call
like chatters. Where's this neocick
person? Neoick call. I'm ready. I'm
calling this neocick person. Dude, I'm
so mad. Disney could be doing godhand.
Disney could be doing god hand.
This person's [__] [__] This
person's [__] [__] Okay,
Neosick, you don't [__] You don't get
it. Hold on. I got to
>> You don't [__] get this [__] dude.
No. Shut the [__] up, [__] Shut the
[__] up, [__] You don't [__] get
this [__]
>> This is not a [__] god hand. Destiny
either one docks the minor who he was
texting or two docks some random DG girl
who also was a minor and he was also in
private DMs with to get the [__]
picture of her in the DG merch. This is
not a god hand. Either way, he's in
private correspondence with a [__]
minor.
>> Have you ever thought about both?
>> Sorry, what was that?
>> Have you ever thought Have you ever
thought about both? Both.
>> Go [__] yourself, dude. [__] this guy.
Holy [__] I'm pissed. I'm [__] mad.
This guy's [__] But this god, if
this is true, if this is true, he's
untouchable. He's untouchable. He's
untouchable.
[__] you. [__] you.
Holy [__]
Oh my god.
One's to be fair, one's obviously worse
than the other. To be fair, one's
obviously worse than the other.
A beautiful hot wife for moral. What?
Why do you guys say these things?
Jesus.
All right. What are they saying?
>> Maybe thought that Well, you know, I'm
pretty confident that she's like
probably an adult, but maybe I can like
>> I'll I'll call you if you have something
to disagree on. I don't know if I just
want to like chat though. What do you
want to talk about?
>> He's pretty confident there.
>> I mean, I've heard that, too. They had
like IRL interactions, you know.
Again,
this is all like like pure speculation
on motive, but yeah,
>> he's had interactions with the
boyfriend.
>> Yep.
>> Wait, no, no. The boyfriend Well, Solo
has said that he's had IRL interactions
with her, right?
>> Oh, I actually don't know. I think I
think there's an implication somewhere.
Honestly, he might have said he says
that he doesn't want to dox Rose cuz
that would have like big effects on him
IRL.
>> Oh, I see. Okay. Also, I I I want this
noted because uh you know, both me and
and JTO have cut ties with Destiny,
unless you you have something you want
to update. To me, JTO, um I couldn't
imagine you guys rekindled your uh your
bond. But, you know, both me and him did
cut ties with him. And the reason I'm
bringing this up is because I
Jacock has claimed more skepticism over
Destiny's
uh uh willingness to like potentially
throw this out there without high
confidence, right, in in her being over
the age of 18. I have have stated
skepticism and that I think he wouldn't
do this without high confidence. If it
turns out that he did do this without
high confidence,
that goes to show even somebody who is
not a fan of Destiny, who had a falling
out with Destiny, that even I am
somebody who do does not have obviously
moral needs a beautiful hot husband.
What? Okay. What What kind of like
content have I done to attract this type
of What? What have I done? What have I
done? What have I [__] I'm so
confused. Where have you people come
from? Where have you people found me
from? Where have you How How did I get
you people in my audience? I'm so
confused.
Whatever, dude.
The fem audience yearns to ship morow.
Do I even have that many female viewer?
I can actually check, right? I can check
the studio. How do I check analytics
audience?
La
I have
I have 17%
17%
uh female audience. W
Let's go. Let's [__] go. Let's
[__] go. Let's [__] go. Also, did
you guys know that YouTube has a uh like
a form function now?
Did you guys know that
YouTube has like a form function? So,
this could this could uh replace the uh
or how do you access it?
Is it only on mobile?
Okay. There there is a forum. I think
it's only on mobile. Hold on.
I hate when they do changes like this.
It's so [__] [__] There is like
a forum on YouTube. I think if you're on
mobile, you can see it.
Visit community.
Yeah, it's this.
How do I access it?
I can see it. Pretty
sure most of those are transgenders cuz
you're liberal and horny. Okay. Well,
I'm one of those things. Okay.
And it's liberal. Okay. You can't access
it on um you can't access it on uh on
desktop for whatever reason, but there
is a community section you can view and
you can make posts there.
So, if you're on mobile, I guess take
advantage of that.
It seems more likely to you that he had
some reason to believe she was over 18
when he posted the pictures of her.
>> That's it. Well, well, yes. So when he
when he posted the well
>> in May when he posted the pictures to
like famous Kiwi Farms people
>> that was him thinking he had significant
reason to believe she was 18
>> or that I mean the other
when he made it public when he made it
public he had significant reason
>> I just realized we've been live for 1
hour we have 75 viewers 25 likes 50 of
you have not liked the stream. Okay,
we're ripping J-Tock content for money.
For money and fame. For money and fame.
We're stealing it. Listen, folks, if you
have not liked the stream. Consider
dropping a like. Consider dropping a sub
if you haven't already. And furthermore,
if you'd like to support the channel in
a more meaningful way, $5 TTS super
chat, meaning if you donate $5 or more,
your chat will be read out loud to both
me and your fellow chatters. as well is
the option for YouTube memberships and
YouTube super stickers, which is an
image or a gift you can put in the side
chat and I'll display it on stream as
well. So, if you're enjoying the
content, if you're enjoying the epic
funny stream, consider, you know,
leaving a dono
goes a long way.
>> It's actually a child. She's actually a
minor when those pictures were posted.
I'm like, "Oh, weird." But I think
you're saying that cuz I found
additional information. Right. So I my
read at the time when this originally
happened was that he said she was a
minor so people wouldn't look into her
background. That was what I thought. Um
that changed
>> Yeah.
>> after a little bit. Yeah. It changed
after a little bit. Just basically um
I don't know. Yeah. It just changed for
me over time. I can't remember exactly
what did it where I was like, "Oh, maybe
he really didn't know." So I I did
originally think at some point that she
probably
Dude Kick sucks. Holy [__] Holy [__] I
told him about it back in the day.
>> Okay. Well,
I was just
>> That's what he was doing. If he was
using my deduction to to go on um
bad luck, buddy. Sorry. Be rough.
>> Yeah.
>> Also, it's rough coming into
conversation like this, especially when
you haven't like I guess like read all
the like KF information. It's like you
are like just just by the nature of that
it's like it's always going to be a
little bit of a rough one but yeah I
think we're saying it's like fair. Um
yeah yeah.
What's your read then? What's your read?
Obviously I I don't think anyone here
like genuinely believes that she was
like a Destiny thinks that she was a
minor um when it was done.
>> Much love though. I am going to go.
>> Wait. I think is not asking you this
question. Hold on. Fine. I thought was
like Wait. I thought Wait. I just I gave
out my read. I thought he was asking
Jar.
>> No, no, no. I was asking. It's fine.
It's fine.
>> Okay. Wait. No. Give me the question. I
thought you were asking Jason.
>> No, no. I was asking that real quick.
Like what what do you think the read is
that like
>> I guess this info is real. I guess with
like Jesse's behavior, maybe some of the
stuff that like we've mentioned here
like you know.
>> Wait, what is the info is real? That
she's like
>> uh
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I I don't I don't know
based on the limited stuff that I've
seen, which actually may not be as
limited as I thought um previously. Uh I
I
I'm not I'm not as convinced as it seems
like of other people of the like face
analysis. Not as convinced. Um but maybe
there's other stuff I haven't seen um
for it. Uh, I just saw like one like
skitso zoomin circle post and I'm not as
convinced by it as it seems like other
people are.
Um, but I also just don't have the full
context for it. So, I don't know.
Frankly, for all of this, this is just
like a potential crime. Um, so I just
expect any federal authorities to
probably potentially handle this. If
they will, and if they don't, then they
don't. Um, you know, I don't think the
general public is ever going to know,
>> dude. This [__] rally guy. I'm I'm
gripping. I'm gripping. Okay. This is
[__]
>> You're upset.
>> I'm upset. I'm upset, dude. This guy, if
Destiny I I I'm so I forgot even his
argument. I'm I forgot why I'm mad. He
said something like, "What if the girl
that Destiny doxed isn't even the minor?
That's his god hand because then you
fell for the bay." But it's like at that
point you've still messaged a minor.
You've messaged two minors now. It's
like this is not a god hand. This is not
a god hand. Pumpern nickel.
>> I think I think I think Rele is uh
>> he wants he I can't even say like he
wants it not to be true. I think um
>> he's sad.
>> He's trying to
>> It's like when you figure out your uncle
killed people in Fallujah, you know?
>> Yeah. Yeah, you're just trying to find
like what the [__] was wrong with those
fusions that that made them deserve it,
right? It's like a little bit of
>> Yeah,
>> he's he's starting with a with a
conclusion that it can't be
the way that it looks and then he's like
rationalizing back from that. I mean,
hey, like it might not be
the way that it looks. Maybe
>> maybe
>> I've been watching the stream off and
on. I'm I'm I'm being more
performatively mad than genuinely. I
don't know what his take really is.
I just want an excuse to yell at a black
man is kind of the crux of that.
>> Oh, you don't you don't need an excuse.
Just go for it.
>> Well, I Well, obviously I would need I
would need something to yell at them
for.
>> Oh, just make something up.
>> Oh, that's true. I got to call Res. I'm
sorry. I got to call this guy now.
Okay. What is this?
What is this guy saying? This guy's like
so gay.
This guy's like so gay.
This guy's like so unfa unfathomably
gay.
Really left. Call him in DMs. Maybe Awol
Hassan streams is just hours uh and
shower. I'm calling Really. He just He
You're not not Really? Resi is not
answering.
>> I'm not I'm not I'm here. I'm here now.
>> Oh, hey.
>> Yeah. What? What? They said you were
sad. Why did they say you were sad?
>> I'm planning on killing myself.
>> Yeah, I know. You say this every stream.
What's new,
>> dude? You're such an You're an [__]
man.
>> I know, but what do you want me to say,
dude? Like,
>> why is it bad that Destiny wanted to
[__] a 17-year-old?
>> Why is it bad that he wanted to [__] a
17-year-old?
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, transmission of CS Sam,
>> but that but that's cool.
>> No, it's not.
>> What?
>> Yeah, moral. Like, you got real close to
the truth at one point.
>> What?
>> You know what I mean? It's the sun. It
burns you. It's like it's like
>> I I got close to the truth.
>> He got close to the sun. Close to the
truth. Got close to the truth of why
Destiny's bad.
>> What was the truth?
>> That we probably would have all called
you a pedophile if you got boobs from
that woman. It's like that's it. Yeah.
>> But that would have been cool.
>> No, I wouldn't have.
>> You'd still like me?
No, probably wouldn't talk to you cuz
I'd just be like, "All right, bud."
>> Okay, well then don't talk to me now,
[__] The only thing that
changed in that encounter, I still had
intent. The the intents that would what
[__] matters, [__]
>> You know, you said it was a joke before
anyways.
>> No, I was flirting with her. I've said
that before.
It's like months old. Have you Did you
miss a stream?
>> I might have missed something in here.
>> I wanted to [__] the 17-year-old Resi.
>> Oh, yeah. I thought you've been joking
about those this whole time.
>> No.
>> Oh,
>> however, I did not I did not sex them. I
did not sex them to be clear.
>> Okay. So, what was the show the boobs
thing then?
>> What do you mean
>> when you said show boobs?
>> Oh, that that specifically was a joke. I
was trying to do like a like an irony
meta irony or something. Yeah,
>> I realized in hindsight it was not that
funny.
funny, actually. Yeah.
>> Yeah, I realized that. That's literally
what I just said. And Oh my god. Okay.
>> Is that what you were referencing?
>> Yes. the show boobs thing. That was like
the only part of that cuz otherwise like
it was like it wasn't even sexual
flirting. The show boobs thing was the
only part that I'm like you said this
was a joke and I'm like yeah okay I kind
of get
>> well I mean it's like a flirty joke I
guess you know.
>> Yeah. Well no it's like I've also like
I've seen other things where that's like
you said that and it's just like okay
cool you know.
I guess listen what I mean like I feel
like um
>> I don't know why is it bad is just seam
that's it cam bad
>> uh transmission of seam lying about the
age
um like I think the lying about the age
thing is like the very particular one
specifically because like
[Music]
>> yeah I mean again like you can like yawn
if you want but it's probably
>> that was a real Yeah, that was That
wasn't fake.
>> Yeah. So, I think there's like an issue
um personally where you've seen the clip
from No Jumper, right?
>> Sure. Just just go off, bro. Just go
off, bro.
>> Okay. So, on No Jumper, he describes
that on Facebook or something like that,
he found these hashtags where
you have that.
>> Yeah. Can you link me?
Uh yeah, I have it in my doc. I can I
can send you that real quick. Okay, so
uh yeah, this was on May 25th, 2023.
Um
which, you know, if you're looking at
this May 25th, 2023,
>> Sure.
um you're specifically seeing him
describe like these kinds of like uh
issues that arise and everything like
that within
um
how to put how do I put it uh issues
that arise within
different platforms like Facebook,
Twitter, etc. having hashtag searches
which are then used by miners to then
sell and distribute stuff. When it came
to the stuff with
uh Willy Mack, you have Destiny telling
Willie Mack that Tinder age verifies
when in reality he doesn't even know if
Rose had Tinder at all at any point,
right? He she just said, "Oh, I'm going
to go [__] some guy off Tinder that I
just met." when in reality Tinder one
doesn't have age checks two she never
provides didn't meet him on Tinder he
met he she met Destiny when she was
selling her nudes he asked for ID never
got it and then just moved on with
everything like it's like they have
those DMs up too I can send you that
here
>> I don't know yeah I guess I guess
Destiny is onlogically evil
Um,
yeah.
>> Okay, hold on. I got to go. Someone sent
me food shops. Food shops clip.
>> Is food shops going over this right now?
>> I don't know what they're doing. I'll
I'll talk I'll I'll keep you posted.
>> Yeah, let me know what food shops is
doing. I got to do my segment on this
trip.
>> Bye.
>> Hey, what is this? I was given a
streamable
>> business then usually. Yeah. Pixie, I
also had a fake a fake what? ID to get
into most bars/clubs in NYC. No one
really cares where your ID is from.
Destiny. Oh, so this is why Destiny does
not trust IDs. Okay, there you go.
Business then
because they can get a fake ID at that
point. Okay.
[Music]
dude. Uh, okay.
The if you are going to engage with
people sexually over the internet, the
bare minimum you can do, the bare
minimum you can do is ask for their age.
And then going a step further is asking
for their ID. If they have a fake ID and
they provide you with a fake ID,
uh that is that is fine because if it
gets leaked and this person turned out
to be like 16 or 17 and you're like,
"Hey, well, I I asked to see their ID.
They showed me their ID. It said they
were, you know, over 21. Um, I had no
reason to believe they were under 21.
Especially, I never met up with this
person. It was just sexing. Like, yeah,
you'd look, you'd look kind of [__]
and, you know, kind of reckless, but at
the same time, like, yeah, that's the
most you can do in a situation like
this, right?
Just doing this gay like I'm not going
to ask for IDs because they can be fake.
It's like if you've if you've set the
standard that you want to ask for ID and
you want to age verify, then do that.
This is like [__]
food shops of all people. Okay, hold up.
We got a donut. Let's hear.
>> Show us your ID so we know you're not a
minor.
>> [__] no.
My ID is also expired.
I should probably get a new one. I
should probably get a new one.
Um,
yeah, just ask for ID. Un unless you're
in a unless you're in an environment
where the what what is the term I'm
looking for? It's like a bar, right? If
you're in an environment where you're in
a bar
the thoughts that are going through your
head is not like um the thought going
through your head is not like uh [__] I
could be talking to a minor. It's like
the environment that you're in there is
some expectation of the individuals
being over 21.
If you're in like a club, the
expectation is that the individuals are
going to be over 18, right? If you're in
an environment where the expectation is
that the individuals are over the age of
consent or over 21 or over whatever,
then yeah, I think it's fine to not ask
someone for an ID. Or, for example,
you're on you're on Tinder or or a
dating site where the expectation is
that someone's over the age of 18, I
don't think you're required to ask for
their ID. Uh but if you meet someone for
example uh through like Minecraft like
you're playing a Minecraft server and
then you start talking to this person
and then you start to engage sexually
with them. I think at that point the
expectation for you know playing
Minecraft is not that they're over 18.
At that point I think you should go a
little bit further and verify their ID
before you interact with them sexually.
Obviously, this is like if you if you
resort to interacting with people
sexually.
Also, this is like um this is just like
a completely [__] argument.
Remember to check IDs unless it's like,
okay, how old was Pixie? Pixie was 20.
Pixie was in college. Pixie was going to
college. You knew her parents, right?
You met her parents. Uh you hung out
with her consistently, constantly. So
acting as if this is like you are not in
an environment where where Pixie would
have been able to use a fake ID on you,
right? You were well into your 30s or
late 20s, early 30s, whatever. you are
in an environment where it would be
impossible pretty much for her to lie
about her age unless her parents are
just perfectly fine with their underage
daughter interacting sexually and
intimately with Destiny, which I don't
think would be the case, right? So, this
is not a situation, this is absolutely
not a situation where the expectation is
that this person has a fake ID or is a
minor, right? So, obviously, nobody
expects you to ask Pixie for their fake
for their ID. There's not a situation
like that, especially when you know them
in person and you've met their parents
and you've talked to their parents and
whatever, right?
This is not that type of situation. Um,
if you meet someone just like Resi even
sent me this clip cuz I believe he met
Rose via the uh the NSFW tag on Twitter,
right? What is it? Twitter NSFW. TWT
NSFW. Is that what it is?
>> I got this guy. This this sex worker.
Shut up. What were you saying? I have no
idea.
>> Like a farright organization that was
pushing the idea that there was a
fuckload of child porn on Pornhub when
in reality there's way more child porn
on like platforms like Facebook than
even on Pornhub.
>> Poor [__] This was the weirdest
Facebook. Okay.
God, this is such a [__] argument.
Holy [__] Okay.
Pornhub is specifically for porn, right?
Pornhub is specifically for porn and you
make money from having porn there,
right?
Having porn, having child porn on
Pornhub is significantly different than
having child porn on something like
Facebook, right? These are two very
different things and two very different
issues. These are not the same issue.
These are two very different issues.
>> It's not publicly facing. Whereas like
Pornhub, you could theoretically just go
search this [__] up, right? Whereas like
>> Facebook the the child porn problem on
Facebook is people sending it in the
messages.
This is the weirdest thing I'd ever
discovered in my entire [__] life.
There was a hashtag I don't remember
what the hashtag was. There was a
hashtag on Twitter for underage people
posting porn.
>> Interesting.
>> Where [__] it was like TWWT or it was
some [__] [__] hashtag. But if
you clicked it, it was a ton of girls
like 15, 16. Someone was posting full-on
[__] porn with hashtags. Like holy
[__]
>> And you believe it was posted by them
and not by other people, which
>> I didn't dig into it that much. I'm
sorry. I should have kind of like
irrelevant who posted it,
>> right? Which is how he even found Rose,
right? So, if you're if you know, and I
believe there's DMs. Hold on. I believe
there's DMs.
Stephen.
Steven here.
What is that meme? You guys know Steven
here?
You guys know that meme?
What is it?
>> 10 years. What's your favorite?
>> I think this is it. Yeah. Let me show
you. Steven here.
>> Steven here.
>> 10 years. What's your favorite sling?
Steven.
>> Steven here.
>> Hello, Stephen.
Steven here.
>> 10th in 10 years. What's your favorite
slang?
>> Steven, sir.
>> Steven here.
>> Hello, Stephen.
>> 10th in 10 years. What's your favorite
slang? Steen.
>> Steven here.
>> Hello, Stephen.
Steven. Steven here.
>> 10 years. What's your favorite Steven?
>> Steven here.
Hello, Stephen.
Stephen here.
>> 10 days in 10 years. What's your
favorite sling? Stevens.
>> Steven here.
>> Hello, Stephen. So, it's kind of like
that. It's kind of like that moment.
Stephen here. Steven here. You're hot as
[__] but 18. WTF? Also, one day old
account. Oh, well. I mean, I'm flattered
if you wanted to. Yeah, sure. Preferably
one year and ID. So, I know you're at
least 18, but I understand if that's too
much. If you'd be uncomfortable showing,
yeah, that's fine. Just writing
something on a piece of paper is more
than enough.
So, he asks for the ID. He's like, "Hey,
if you're uncomfortable showing it," and
he's like, "You know what? You can
verify it just with a pen and paper."
So, yes, if you're if you're if you meet
a one-day old account and they're 18,
uh, and you begin interacting with them
sexually, uh, I don't think it's like
insane to say like, yeah, you should go
one step further because again, right
here, here are the two situations. Here
are the two situations that happen if
she has a fake ID, right? You either
one, you don't request an ID, you don't
verify their age, and they turn out to
be a minor. You look [__] ridiculous.
You look like a dumb [__] You look like
a predator, right?
Especially given like your rhetoric and
and given the recklessness and stuff
like that. Uh,
destiny is a predator of opportunity,
whatever, right? Especially if you're in
your 30s. Yeah, I can give some leeway
to people who are like younger. But if
you're in your 30s and you meet an
18-year-old, I I think there should be
some uh due diligence there, maybe.
However,
let's say she does have a fake ID. Let's
say you do verify that. Then it is no
longer on you. Okay? Yeah, it's going to
be a little weird. You're going to get a
little [__] for it. Whatever. But you
did your due diligence. You looked into
it. You tried to understand like, "Hey,
how old are you? Okay, I see your ID. I
see that you're over 18. Okay, now I can
interact with you sexually."
But Destiny didn't do that, right?
Instead, he didn't verify their age at
all, and they turned out to be a minor.
Right.
Steven here.
>> 10 years in 10 years. What's your
favorite thing? Stevens.
>> Steven here.
>> Hello, Stephen.
Hello, Stephen.
Is Dicker stolen? What is Dicker saying?
>> Seems like Discord
name fill out the [__] form.
>> So I go back to
>> he wants to have an autistic exercise in
discussing whether or not Destiny
Why can't we call a spade a spade? This
[__] is scum. He's scum. And multiple
people have tried to tell you. Multiple
people have tried to say it. I'm not
saying you specifically Jaytock. I'm
saying to anybody who's [__]
listening. He's [__] scum.
>> Benny.
>> Okay. I mean, I use scum, too.
>> Again, you let me know if I'm going too
far.
It's not
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Obviously, no threats and
[__] on the stream. Okay.
>> No, no, okay. No, no, no. Absolutely
not. Nach, I'm not going to threaten
anybody. I don't want anybody to get
hurt. I I don't agree with violence.
Violence is bad.
>> Isn't that the gamer guy that hates you?
The gamer guy. Huh?
>> Even resembling responsibility,
resembling caring about other people,
and he doesn't take care of his own
[__] son. You taught me if I go too
far.
Whoa. Can we say that now? For years it
was like, "Hey man, don't talk about
other people's kids."
>> No. No. I'm I'm gonna keep the Nathan
boycott on.
>> Okay.
>> I think the shitty thing with that is
that um his son is like uh his son's
like a victim of him basically. I I
don't think like I get nothing out of
bringing him up. It's just it like it
only hurt one person. Desie's got no
feelings. He's got no he's there's like
no human there. I'm not saying it to
hurt Destiny's feelings. I agree he's a
socio I've come on this stream and I've
argued with Destiny in this stream that
he's a sociopath and a narcissist. I
agree. What I want to do is I want to
hurt his ability to make money so he can
hurt other people. I want nobody to
watch him and they need to understand
that he's a piece of [__] garbage.
So, I understand you have concerns about
his son. I don't want to use I don't
necessarily want to use his son as a
chess piece. I want to point out that
he's always being a piece of [__]
garbage.
>> Yeah. He has.
He definitely has.
>> I'm watch I'm listening to Rei. He's
going He's going He's going, "Well,
>> Rey's not Rey's not acting like he's a
good person." Really saying that there
must be
>> No, I I understand his rational
self-interest. I think if you think he's
a total psychopath, right?
>> Then that probably there is probably
like a good You should feel like that,
right? Where's the Where's the
self-interest here?
>> Well, no. I I don't I I don't know
what's wrong with him.
>> Okay.
All right.
Do you think D should be depersoned?
What does that word even mean?
Depersoned.
Definite.
Uh
suffering the damaging or lack of
effects of employment. What?
Oh, that's depressed. What?
D
person
meaning
depersons to remove the qualities that
make someone special or unique. I don't
know what you're asking.
I don't know what you're asking. Um, do
I think he should be deplatformed or
banned? I think if he's breaking to he
should be banned.
Do I think you should be banned for
outside crimes? Uh, no. No.
No. I don't think so.
I think if we made it so like if YouTube
changed their policy to where they could
ban someone for outside crimes and then
Destiny's crimes fit the criteria, then
yes.
But just arbitrarily banning him, I
think is a slippery slope I don't want
to go down.
>> I think Destiny is one of the worst
people on the internet right now. I
think in a lot of ways he's worse than
bad empanada. Uh and I think everybody
who's defending him or ignoring him or
justifying his actions is uh a terrible
person as well. Uh like food shops. Food
Shops is a
genuinely disgusting individual for uh
standing by uh and defending this [__]
Uh I'm going to host food shops until
they turn into an antifan. Then once
they've evolved enough, I'll raise two
to three more massive antifans. Then
I'll get five of them to fight each
other. War of the five anti-an kings.
Listen, I would like I would love to
think that food shops has enough
self-awareness and uh free will to uh
ultimately see the see the path, see
that Destiny is a wretched lying scum
[__] piece of [__] But um
I am not at all confident in that. I am
not not at all confident in that at all.
Um
I think in their mind they're finally
getting viewership and they're finally
getting clout and recognition even
though they're like a [__] [__]
with no like opinions. Uh so they're
probably going to keep doing it.
They're probably going to keep doing
whatever they're doing.
Isn't food shops an aunt? Yep.
I
>> did Lo ever send you that clip? Uh, no.
What clip?
Hm.
None of us thought we'd be here 5 years
ago, man. I Yeah, I definitely didn't. I
was definitely drinking the Kool-Aid for
a period there. Okay. Not great.
It's not I can't hear it. Okay. All
right. People can't hear the music, so
it's fine. Jesus. Okay.
Yeah. I appreciate all your feelings,
Benny. You say the things I want to say
but can't.
Okay.
>> Things I feel.
>> Why can't?
>> Uh cuz cuz
I don't like sewing out. Sometimes
showing out is the right response.
>> Oh, I think I did see that on.
>> Yeah, there is a lot a lot a lack of
soy. As far as I'm concerned, there's a
lack of soy.
>> Too much giga chatting.
>> Pick the n word. Why? You guys aren't
funny.
I will just be your pay. Hold on. You
said donated $5. Destiny has somehow
pulled off parasocial abuse. Every time
we accepted one of his explanations for
abhorrent behavior, our conscience is
squashed and we become desensitized to
narcissistic abuse.
>> Um, possibly.
>> All right.
>> [__]
Oh.
Um,
what do we cover? What do you guys want
to see? Can I uh What do I What do I
cover in order to get more donos? What
can I cover in order to get some money?
Should we just A-log food shops? Would
you guys dono for that? Dono for food
shops. Alogging. There's this a couple
tweets I wanted to look at. Yeah,
there's this where Destin I mean, I kind
of brought this up earlier. Destiny just
docks as the girl.
Then there's this
uh let's zoom out a little bit. I don't
know. I haven't dug into it all, but she
told me she was 19. And there are logs
confirming as such. If she was ever
underage, then I expect all of them will
be running into that solo guy because he
was recording 60 plus gigabytes of porn
with her. Yeah. I mean, obviously Solo
is bad for doing that. Solo is bad for
doing that. Obviously, I don't think
anybody's defending Solo. Uh then Solo
says, "Anyway, she was underage while
sending you the vast majority of that
stuff. And from what I've heard uh from
her, you were pretty negligent about
confirming her age. Even asked for an ID
at one point on Twitter, then saying it
was okay slash a joke." Uh which we saw
confirmed in DMs, right?
Then there's obviously just a
compilation of the other messages.
There's a [__]
Since when did you care about the
children? Except for Rose by uh his kid.
Jesus. Bleak. Bleak. Bleak stuff. Holy
[__]
Jesus.
Terrible. Terrible. Terrible. Terrible.
Obviously, we've uh kind of looked
through these, but
>> her name is Dolly. Seven months old, she
may not be the monster imagined in a
science fiction fantasy. Yet, the cuddly
Finn Dorset lamb may represent a major
landmark in the history of genetic
engineering.
>> True.
>> On an ordinary farm in Scotland,
scientists say a clone was created from
a sing
>> Okay. [__] What did I say I was going
to look at? Oh, yeah. The Connor ship. I
can look at the Connor [__]
Where is my Yeah, this guy [__] DM'
me the [__] This guy DM' me the sauce,
bro. Let's look at this Connor ship.
Uh, Connor points coping about Destiny/
Rose time stamps one through five are
short. Just responding to donos. The
last one is the meat. See the screen
cap?
What the [__]
All right, let's get all these uh time
stamps ready then.
Take a look at all these
>> crisis
and he came back on a different
all right
uh nightwell gang says
okay
so let's start at this.
>> Good to be back into the routine. Hi,
Dis Houseion. Thank you for your
donations yesterday. Hello, Dan S. And
um I was just going to say we we got
some uh Oh, I'm I'm not going to lie,
I've been trying to cover other things
besides Destiny uh just to mix it up and
make sure that we don't become a Destiny
Rewatch channel. Uh, however, uh, truth
be told, there's a reason why he's the
most popular streamer in liberal news
media. There's a reason why he's
constantly the center of attention and
drama. It's because he gets into fights
with other people all the time. Uh,
which is what we'll be talking about
today.
[Applause]
Okay. Well, that's part of it. I guess
that's part of the reason why
Spotlight's always on him. Real shalah.
Indeed. Indeed. Um, how old was Rose? No
idea. 1718
>> now. I don't care. Uh, let let me tell
you.
>> 1718. All right.
>> Why I don't care.
>> Uh, he doesn't care.
>> We already knew that. We've known that
for a year. Um, that like Rose was like
living with her parents and all that
kind of [__]
>> So, well, maybe not a year. Maybe
November. November. So, we we've known
that she was living with her parents and
it was [__] stupid and all that
[__] Um, so I don't know. Se 17
years old, 364 days and and 11 hours. No
idea. No idea. And you know what? I hope
that the entire drama of sexing random
people on the internet, of sending
homemade pornography to various people,
of having it leaked, of getting sued
over it. Um, I hope that has been and
will continue to remain a wakeup call
for Steven to not be so hedonistic and
nihilistic.
Um, and that's all we can pray for is
that he becomes a better person over
time. So, anyways,
>> okay. I understand Connor's perspective
here. It just feels [__] um does it
feel naive? Maybe
naive. It it it feels like, okay, you
keep wanting him to do better. You keep
wanting him to be a better person, to be
better, to do better. Destiny's pushing
[__] 40. Destiny's pushing 40, man.
All right. He is getting up there in
age. And every single time you've said
we can only pray for him to get better,
uh, somehow it's gotten worse. So,
at what point do you just kind of cut
your losses, you know? But whatever.
That is a super big problem.
CPA says, "I can understand you wanting
to support your friend, I guess, but
working with someone sexing a
17-year-old seems crazy politically, but
you do you, I guess." Well, thanks for
that. Um, do you does anybody have
evidence that she was 17?
Se
What? You just said she was 17 in the in
like three hours prior at the beginning
of the stream. You said she was 17.
All right,
>> Rose girl. I I don't Is there something
new? Cuz you're you're not the first
person.
>> There's like half a dozen people who are
like, "Destiny's bad. Destiny's bad.
Disavow him now."
>> So, I'm curious.
>> Have dated.
>> So, that means 30% of them have had a
relationship.
>> Sorry, did I mess up?
>> Yes, on KF. Well, I mean, that's our
first problem. Uh, but realistically,
what's the evidence on KF?
>> Did I miss? You're saying both 30% of
women
>> have not dated.
>> Have not dated.
>> Okay. Sorry.
So that so if it's two to one men not
dating but women are dating then the
women would have to be dating.
>> Well between that age well no no that's
the age bracket 18 to 25 is one of the
key things.
>> Okay. Okay. So but the point is
>> women are dating older men.
>> Oh I see. I see. I see.
>> That's what's making up the gap.
>> I think everyone agrees with that.
Right.
>> Well uh yeah I mean the reality is you
know average women don't want average
men. They date up. and not only
reinforced, but it's encouraged. Uh, you
know, women are told to not settle.
They're told to get the best man that
they can get. So, a lot of girls think
that they qualify for something a lot of
times, which they actually don't. Um,
and sometimes I have to be the reality
and let them know like, look, you're
average.
>> All right. Well, let's go to the next
one.
>> And we've got no young people. Jenna
>> Ryan Cougler says, "Has Connor commented
on the story of the day, chat? Thanks in
advance. Yeah. Uh, Steven's a pedophile,
but your guy's evidence of him being a
pedophile is that he allegedly sent
videos to a 17-year-old girl.
>> Sent and received. He received. The big
part of that is received.
>> He was sending 17-year-old videos back.
Uh, but I don't know what you're talking
about.
>> Okay. Well, he he did clarify. I guess
that's fine.
>> Evidence is we already knew Rose was a
young girl. We've already commented on
the fact that creating and distributing
homemade pornography is [__] stupid.
Uh I think we've also commented on the
fact that sending it to very young girls
is [__] stupid. Uh and I don't think
that definitionally makes you a
pedophile. Makes you stupid. Um I I
don't think
>> I mean I agree with that. Again, I don't
think the issue is that the issue is
Okay. Okay. Is Destiny a pedophile?
Probably not for this though. is
Destiny. What is the issue with that age
gap? What is the issue with her being
17? The issue isn't that a [__]
17-year-old is too [__] to
understand what type of [__] she's into
or doing or whatever, right? That's not
the issue. A 17-year-old is not really
victimized. There isn't a [__] magic
barrier. You cross between 17 and 18
that suddenly she would have had all the
foresight to understand what she was
doing. Uh the issue is that Destiny is
like insanely reckless and negligent uh
and should not be someone uh and
negligent to the point of like
victimizing uh women whether it's
sending revenge porn around, whether
it's sexually assaulting women, whether
it's uh you know potentially interacting
with minors in a sexual manner, right?
Sending and receiving CESAM. Um
so the issue here is not that she's 17,
it's a broader systematic issue with
Destiny. Uh and I think I I think that's
what's being ignored. Uh, this is not
someone you should want to back up
politically. This is someone who is a
dangerous individual, right?
They're saying it to make Destiny looks
stupid instead of perverse. No, I
understand what they're saying. Destiny
is a is a danger. I think that is the
that is the crux here. Destiny is a
danger. Destiny is a dangerous
individual that you should not back
politically or otherwise.
And the issue here, Connor Connor's like
doing well. 20K sub channel in like a
couple months. He's doing well. Connor
could do his own [__] He doesn't need
destiny.
Like in my in my in my perfect world,
Connor would step back and become his
own political [__] pundit or
whatever. But obviously that's not going
to happen.
Destiny is not stupid. He He is He is a
danger.
That is what you need to [__]
understand at this point.
You can only make so many mistakes
before it's uh a pattern. And I get, you
know, the mistakes could be a pattern,
but at this point, you know, it makes
you question it at the very least.
>> Like it makes you a pedophile. So I I
hope I hope you got your clip, Ryan
Cougler. I hope that helps you.
>> Alpha is only 40 million people. It is
half the size of the millennials.
>> Sure. So to this, I would basically say
I agree that there has been a lot of
cons that have
>> Gazippy says he sent and received. Okay.
Well, I need to see the evidence, but
you know, good. Good for you. I guess
>> have come with giving women agency. I
>> He's doing this like weird like
double-sided thing where it's like, yes,
she was 17, but also I need proof. It's
like, okay, well, I mean, whatever.
Whatever. All right. What's this?
>> It was the same PFP, different name, and
then he was powing around for a while,
and I don't know if he
>> Okay, I think we get the point of these.
It's just going to be him talking about
whatever. Let's go
to
this.
There's this quote from Full Metal
Jacket I quote all the time. Inside
every Vietnamese person is an American
waiting to come out. Now he didn't
>> what? Huh?
>> Didn't say Vietnamese person. He said
the the G slur, the go K slur,
>> but I actually I stand by that
sentiment.
>> Inside a lot of people are Americans. So
anyways, let me go ahead and draw this.
There was somebody who get it and they
were being a little bit of a smartass
but they weren't being like too bad.
>> Um I think it was Jen and papering Jtock
now and not spicy. Right. Right. So let
me show you the accusation. Okay. So
Spicy Chat is largely
uh Chud's Discord, right? It's a channel
in Chud's Discord. By the way, I support
Chud's mission of having a place that is
uh Chudlo Logic
that is uh terms of service only. So you
can discuss whatever you want to discuss
as long as it's within terms of service.
That's my understanding of uh Spicy,
right? And somebody from Spicy can
correct me if I'm wrong.
Then
Connor, about the anti-fan [__] one
thing you need to pay attention to is
that would want to moral frog you. They
have this moral supremac uh supremacist
when the people they had support follow
are not that different. Uh sure, but we
should still contend arguments on their
face. Even if the arguments are bad
faith, I don't and I'm not saying bad
faith to moral frog. I'm saying bad
faith as in they're not doing they're
not doing it because they actually care
that Steven was goo a gooner several
years ago. They're doing it because
they're trying to get all the people. I
also agree when people say that when
when people address Destiny as just a
gooner or just a sex pest. I feel like
that's downplaying.
I feel like that's downplaying.
The severity of what he has done is is
way more significant than just gooning
or just being a sex past. I'm a [__]
gooner. Okay, I'll DM women on Discord.
I'm not above that and I'll [__] I'll
own that [__] right? Um but Destiny is
not just DMing women on Discord. Destiny
is not just horny posting on Discord.
Destiny is committing multiple sex
crimes that potentially involve minors.
This has gone from, you know, gooning
and and whatever to to something very
very different. Um,
and I don't like that people describe it
as just gooning or just being a sex
best. I think that's very there there is
something very different uh and way more
dangerous going on that people should
address head-on, I think. And this weird
downplay is uh is really [__] and I
don't like it. I don't like it. I don't
like this weird downplay people do
>> around Stephen to call Steven a piece of
[__] and to distance themselves from
him. That's obviously the objective or
it seems like the objective.
So unless there's new information,
uh I'm not I'm not ch I'm not changing
my perspective unless there's new
information, right?
Um, so spicy chat,
uh, Discord terms of service
service
are the only rules. Okay, that that's
spicy chat as far as I understand it.
Want to be able to see spicy chat,
right? There we go. Okay. Are the only
rules. Then we have uh Queman, who let's
admit it, um Chud does want to um have
Quean be his own entity.
And that's true. I I think Queman, what
what does he get? He gets between like
300 and 700 viewers depending on what
he's talking about. I think Queman,
>> if I'm proud of 100 to 200 live viewers,
depending on topic, I think Queman
should be proud of 300 to 700. So, I
would say Queman started as a a Chudlo
Chudlogic Orbiter. Uh, but he's
effectively his own drama YouTuber now
>> in my opinion.
>> Okay, he's spinning.
>> Then we have And then we got like Kord
Kord.
>> What the [__] is Kord?
>> Kord
or Queensman's dis. Oh, Queman's. Okay,
sure.
Uh,
>> here we go. Let's do a square.
And I don't know uh Queman's rule set,
but I'm assuming it's similar to spicy
chat. So, I'm just going to put similar,
right?
Similar to spicy chat. Similar to spicy
chat uh in that you can pretty much
endlessly, as a matter of fact, I'll
rewrite it. Uh endlessly talk [__] about
anybody. I don't know what their terms
of service are, but that's that's the
kind of culture in my opinion is that
you can endlessly talk [__] about
anybody in Quean and that's not a terms
of service violation. Being like
manically focused on a single person is
not a terms of service violation and
it's also not like a community
violation. They're not going to kick you
out for that. And then JTO
in my opinion is like the number one
Destiny Alog,
right? Jtock and I'm gonna put Riyle. I
know that they're supposed
>> Okay. Well,
I don't know if I agree there. The
number one. I mean, hyperbolically,
sure, but no, I don't think so. Maybe
Riyle on his own. I dude, the the the KF
thread like posts like [__] clips of
him all the time, right? I would assume
the KF thread is is way more of an ALOG
than like the gistical community.
And to be clear, the the JTO server is
super super censored. You cannot be like
super edgy there or like super [__]
there. You'll get muted and banned like
pretty frequently. Um
they pick and choose a lot to be fair.
They pick and choose who should be
banned and who should stay. They don't
really have standards, but uh people
you'll get banned from JTO super easily
whereas like Queensman's and Shuds, I
don't think you would. supposedly not
affiliated, but JTO got banned off of
YouTube very early on. And so Riyle, in
my opinion, they don't have to agree
with me, but Riyle is effectively like
uh
he is Destiny's like number one YouTube
alog. He takes all of the Jtock hate
streams and he publishes them to
YouTube.
So, uh, number one,
>> uh, number one,
uh, Destiny Alog, right?
>> And so,
>> cuz JTO's a total [__] Okay, JTO does
not often ban people. It's mostly the
mod team. The mod team is super
inconsistent, and it's mostly dependent
on who's online.
was that I think that everybody will
agree
that there is a substantive amount of
cross-pollination
between these three
uh chats. And the reason why is because
Chud Logic just likes to cover whatever,
right? Like like he's an equal
opportunity drama frog. Although,
weirdly enough, he has distanced himself
from
uh Twitch and YouTube politics. And so,
as a result, I actually think he has
less Destiny Alogs than Queen or
Destiny, but I think they still have
like a similar like vibe, right? And so,
the accusation is that in spicy chat, I
forget who this guy's name is, Courtnoi,
Court Rose, Court, right?
>> What? Who
>> is that? There was a guy named Court
something who was famous on
>> I'm guessing this is like an older an
older individual
>> Kiwi Farms. He was in Spicy Chat. He
docked somebody. He was banned. Then
after he was banned, he came in on an
alt PFP and he was allowed to be in the
Discord for a prolonged period. And I
have no idea how long he was in there.
Again, I don't know the details, but
effectively the accusation is that all
three of these communities like
uh they they enjoy kiwi farms, right?
Uh
no, I don't agree with that.
>> Now, that's not a crime. It's not It's
not a crime to en enjoy kiwi farms. I
think it makes you a little bit of a
schizophrenic, but it it's not a
>> I don't agree with that. I don't agree
with that. I think most of these
communities have felt the uh the burn
from KF and what KF is willing to do to
[__] with people or the people on KF.
Again, KF is not a [__] entity. It's
like the people on there, some of them
are pretty extreme, others are like tame
and they'll just spectate, whatever. But
no, I don't think any of these people
are like massive Kiwi Farms users. I
think you'll find one or two obviously
be being hyperbolic or whatever. you
you'll find your individuals in these
audiences that use KF. Um, but this is
commentary adjacent, you know, spaces.
Um, DG and commentary have always been
adjacent to each other. Destiny has used
KF. Destiny has promoted KF. Destiny has
sent people to KF. Um, acting as if it
is just these communities, like this is
a unique thing, I think is a little
unfair. Um, I think this is a broad
internet commentary thing rather than
just a anti- Destiny thing. This is a
Destiny uses KF. Destiny has a [__]
account on KF, which is already far more
involvement than most creators will do.
Um,
see, I think this framing is a little
dishonest, uh, considering how many like
pro DG people also use KF
>> crime, right? And to hear the way that
I've heard Chudlo Logic and Queman talk
about Kiwi Farms, they effectively say
that it's a drama archive.
That's what they they think it is. It's
that is what it is. Yeah.
I would say a good um
from what very little I know about KF, I
would say a good
above 50%. At least at least.
Uh but a good a vast majority of people
use it as a drama archive and to talk
shed. Um you'll have your one or two
people that dox
and stuff like that, but the majority of
the people there are just archive
content, right?
And the doces are the docses are are a
loud minority. I I I feel everybody on
there isn't doxing, right?
Okay. If you say if you say slurs in the
Discord, you can't complain when you get
[__] banned, [__] Holy [__] Don't
say slurs if you don't want to get
[__] banned from the community.
Don't say slurs in the Discord, okay?
>> Internet schizophrenics
talking [__] about
uh various
uh various characters, but it's a drama
archive that hosts doc's
and uh porn, by the way. Uh because they
had Pixie porn there for a while. And so
the whole
>> you say the n word all the time. I said
a soft a.
Abide by the discord rules. Follow to no
physical threats doxing etc. No spamming
18 plus only. Abide by the discord rules
buddy.
>> Point is that like technically none of
this is illegal right? Talking [__]
about people
uh getting public information all that
kind of stuff. None of that's illegal.
But the argument, change it to red. The
argument is that,
sorry, let me uh that host docsis isn't
porn. Okay, I need to rewind. What does
he say there?
Is this not a porn site? Saying that it
hosts porn is like a major aspect of
what it is is uh is inaccurate. uh
various
uh various characters, but it's a drama
archive that hosts doc's
and
>> dude, I get so mad. People use docs with
two X's
and it makes me so [__] mad. It's a
one. Okay, whatever. Whatever. Whatever.
>> And uh porn, by the way. Uh because they
had Pixie porn there for a while.
>> I think they still do. And so the whole
point is that like technically none of
this is illegal, right? Talking [__]
about people,
uh, getting public information, all that
kind of stuff. None of that's illegal.
But the argument, change it to red. The
argument is that,
sorry, let me uh
>> What's the argument? What's the
argument?
Okay, it's fine. I want to do a new one
now. Thank you.
Okay. So the argument is that there is
an uncomfortable level of familiarity
between spicy chat cord and JTO's
community that goes to Kiwi Farms and
basically gets that information,
popularizes it within the Twitch and
YouTube political community and then
does the things that we saw today where
effectively we had half a dozen to a
dozen people. Okay, I
>> I I hate doing the what aboutism [__]
but this is the same [__] that Destiny
does, you know?
But what but what about this guy? What
about this guy? Okay, I I understand,
right? What aboutism [__] is gay and
sucks? Uh, and it it feels like
non-engagement, but I feel like I I'm
obligated to say this. What about
Destiny? Like,
Destiny has done this more explicitly,
right? Uh, this is a case where you
should lead by example. Uh, which is why
again, like I was [__] arguing in
Jtock server in the gen chat last night.
I feel like people are sacrificing their
principles and their morals uh because
it's destiny. I feel like a lot of
people are sacrificing what they believe
in and what they believe to be good and
bad and they're crossing over those
lines, those boundaries that they have
previously set just because it's about
destiny this time. And I don't think
that that I don't think we should
sacrifice our morals and our principles
uh to go after destiny. I think and
again I'm a [__] naive idealistic
[__] I think uh we should try to be
better. We should strive to be better
than this.
You know, I think stooping down to his
level, stooping down to doxing people,
to promoting doces, to spreading doces,
to doing whatever, I think is bad. I
don't think we should stoop down to that
level. I think that is a bad thing to
do. And I think it makes us no better
than him.
We came in and they're like, "Oh, you
know Destiny's a pedophile, right? You
know Destiny is a pedophile, right? You
know, Dusty's a pedophile, right? The
evidence is on uh the evidence is on
Kiwi Farms. The evidence is on Kiwi
Farms. The EV evidence is on Kiwi Farms.
And so what Stephen is saying is, "Okay,
you're my number one Alog.
You're the largest Twitch and YouTube
person who
um who has Destiny Alogs in your
community. You're the second largest
Destiny Alog/drama
person. all of your communities are
going into Kiwi farms and you're taking
a look at, you know, uh, revenge porn
and doxes and all that kind of stuff.
And then when Steven and his orbit get
doxed, you act like, well, I Chud Logic
can probably truthfully say, well, I
have nothing to do with that and I don't
encourage that bad.
>> Okay, again, the framing here is like
really dishonest.
The framing here is really dishonest.
When when people make arguments like
this, and I don't know if Connor's doing
this. I don't want to believe Connor's
like a dishonest [__] loser piece of
[__] I don't want to believe that. But
when people make arguments like this,
what they're essentially saying is um
Destiny is the only people Destiny have
upset is commentary and JTO and Quean
and Chud. That is the only people
they've upset. They completely ignore
that this guy has violated the consent
of multiple women, which would upset
people outside of this sphere.
You know,
they completely disregard that this guy
has had yearslong beef with Hassan,
who again is going to talk about this
[__] They completely forget about, you
know, having beef with Vosch, with Mr.
Girl, with uh [__] Nick Fuentes, with
all of these people, right?
with all of these people.
Um, so it is really reductive to just
say it is it is these three communities
that are that are a logging uh Destiny.
I don't think you can name it to one
single [__] community and I don't
think you can control your communities.
I think the best you can do is say,
"Hey, don't do this. If I find out
you're doing it, if I find out you're
participating in doc [__] you'll be
banned." Which people have abided by.
You know, look at [__] Spencer Howard
who spread an alleged dox which, you
know, thank it wasn't a picture of his
wife or whatever. Uh, and he was banned
from spicy chat, right? There's not much
more you can do.
Like what is what is I guess the
expectation? Destiny has has set the
framework, set the groundwork for uh
going to KF, for doxing people, for pro
for promoting doxing, encouraging
doxing, all of this [__] He has laid
out that form of attack, that avenue of
attack. He is the one who popularized
that in these communities and then he
will burn these people. He will [__]
with these people to the point where
they don't want to associate with him
and then, you know, Destiny will lose
some fans along the way. They'll go to
these communities and then they'll, you
know, do the learned behavior from
Destiny, right? Uh this this comes from
Destiny. Destiny is the one doing this.
I don't think doxing was as ever as
popular as it was online until recently
in this space at least
behavior can probably truthfully say I
have nothing to do with that and I don't
engage in that behavior. Jtock and Ry
Kittenhouse can say well I have nothing
to do that do with that and I don't
encourage that kind of behavior. But
effectively what happens is a
substantive amount of the content that
JTO produces is Destiny is the most evil
piece of [__] on the [__] planet and
deserves to die and burn in hell. Uh
Quimman also seems to have, I'm going to
put it tactfully, a quite negative
opinion of Stephen. And then uh Queman
calls Steven a [__] for complaining
about getting doxed and harassed.
And so I mean if if I had to summarize
what's going on right now, this is why
Chudlo Logic hasn't been doxed but
Stephen has I believe launched a
counterdoc uh operation against Ral
Kittenhouse Jtock and his orbiters.
>> Okay, it's not counter if none of these
people have doxed anybody to begin with.
Like, dude, I just I like I I feel like
I feel like,
and this is going to be [__] cringe
coming from me, I'm sure. I feel like
Connor has so much [__] potential,
and he's just wasting it on on trying to
[__] defend Destiny.
I really do. I feel like this guy has
has an insane amount of potential. This
guy is a good talker. He's a good
speaker. He's a good debater, but he's
just wasting it all on defending [__]
Destiny.
They launched a counterattack. It's
like, no, there's no counterattack. None
of these people participate in doxing.
Jtock has never doxed anyone. Riyle, to
my knowledge, has never doxed anyone.
Queen, to my knowledge, has never doxed
anyone. Chud, to my knowledge, has never
doxed anyone. So, what is the
counterattack? Oh, it's because, you
know, Destiny is uh being being
criticized and he's getting upset based.
Cool.
>> And I think they've also launched a
counterdoc operation against Queenman. I
don't know. I don't involve myself in
these gay operations, but the reason why
is because they're effectively
uh facilitating the Kiwi Farms community
to be co-hosted and cross-pollinated
into the Twitch and YouTube political
scene. That's the
>> Yes, that's because of Destiny. That's
because of Destiny
>> accusation. I'm not saying it's correct.
I don't know the evidence. I don't
participate in uh I I know that court
corduroy courty courty. I know that
thing was documented that there was a
chudlogic person or not chudlogic
person. I'm sorry. I genuinely
apologize. I'm not trying to make a
negative association. Um, there was a
Kiwi farmer in Spicy Chat who was banned
and then came back under an alt. I know
that that incident was uh documented,
but but I don't know anything else with
that.
Um, what did Destiny do with Keles
again? Uh, wrote a manifesto and pointed
and and and admitted that there was a
hyperdocumented
Keles Kiwi Farms thread. Right.
That's fair. That feels like an accurate
description of reality. No, I mean I'm
happy to take uh any criticisms of my
graph.
Uh no nope says, "If you aren't changing
your opinion on Destiny, why are you why
are you entertaining these juice stalker
cucks?" Uh because I try to follow the
truth wherever it leads me. Right.
Jeffrey Hinkle says, "I don't care about
the gooning, but the doxing seems weird
to me." Okay, I mean I agree with you
there, but okay. Wasn't trying to be bad
faith. Okay, listen.
>> Like dude, just [__] disavow. just
say this is explicitly bad and he should
not be doing that. Like I don't know. I
don't know. Maybe I'm moral fagging.
Maybe I'm moral fagging. Maybe I'm moral
fagging.
>> What is Jtock up to? What's Jtock doing?
>> Doing? He's like trying to shape
opinions from the shadows.
>> He's doing the same [__]
>> Very concerning. I need to update you on
this.
>> All right.
What else is going on? What should we
look at? cuz I uh I'm going to end
if we don't find something to look at
soon. I'm probably just going to end
um
la
music segment.
Um,
top 10 favorite cat colors. I'm not
picky when it comes to cat colors.
I don't think if you I don't think
people would care about the 40k [__] to
be fair.
Wait,
I'm actually just lying to you. I
already I watched this off stream.
I watched it off stream. I literally
agree with everything said in the video.
I watched off stream. I literally agree
with everything said in the video.
How long have you been live? Only two
and a half hours. [__]
[__]
[__] Um,
I don't know.
Murder mystery commentary.
Why don't you call in Rosie? Why don't
you debate me on something? What's up,
Rosie? What are you doing? You're a
freak. You know that you're a [__]
freak.
Um,
how Tro Trollzus got away with it. Who's
Trollzus?
evil.
Um,
temp me. What does that mean, dude?
Yeah, I think we're just going to end.
I'll write into like resi or something.
I don't want to [__]
realistically
realistically I could just like farm
food shops content, but I I feel like
that's uh
I feel like that's just kind of
just like lowbrow and like I'm kind of
bored of it to be honest. I'm kind of
bored of it. It's like I'm pretty much
just going to agree with everything they
say because they they literally have
like the opposite takes uh of everything
that I have.
Uh and there's not really much else
going on other than like the Ethan [__]
and the Destiny [__] And I feel like
I've talked about that already.
Um
yeah. All right. I'm going to raid into
resi and just go work on my video. Bye
guys. Love you. Love you. Bye. Bye.
Smile. Bye. Smile. Bye.